We keep a lot of information on our
mobile phones, our tablets, and our
other mobile devices. So, it's always a
good idea to keep that data safe by
encrypting everything that we store on
any of these devices. That way, if the
device happens to be out of our control,
we still know that all of that data will
remain safe. If you're using an Apple
iOS or iPad OS device, then all of your
personal data is going to be encrypted
and your passcode provides the
decryption key. Android has a similar
feature and it also uses your login
pattern pin or passcode to be able to
encrypt this data. This feature is
usually on by default with most of these
devices and if you're not currently
using encryption on your mobile device,
you might want to consider enabling it
on your phone.
These mobile devices not only store our
sensitive information, they also provide
access to important external resources
like our bank account or credit card
information. To be able to protect all
of these, we need to make sure that
we're using screen locks. This is going
to restrict any access to our mobile
devices if somebody happens to pick it
up or gain access to it. There are many
different ways to lock this screen. One
easy way to lock and unlock the screen
is using facial recognition. You simply
pick up your phone and the camera on
your phone performs facial recognition
and then unlocks the phone if you're
authorized. You could also use a
personal identification number that you
type in each time you'd like to unlock
the phone. Or you could use a built-in
fingerprint reader if your mobile device
supports that. And another interesting
locking mechanism is one you might see
on Android devices where you would swipe
a particular pattern and only after
using the correct pattern will your
phone unlock.
You can also configure what happens if
somebody tries to gain access to your
phone multiple times with a failed
unlock code. On iOS, there's an option
to erase data. This will erase all data
on the phone after 10 failed passcode
attempts. This is another good reason to
have backups of all of your systems,
especially if it's a cloud-based backup
because anyone can pick up your phone,
use 10 different attempts to log in, and
suddenly everything on your phone is
erased. A similar feature happens with
Android. It locks the device after a
number of login attempts and then you
must provide your Google login or you
have to wipe the device and start from
the beginning.
Many organizations will have centralized
management for all of their mobile
devices through mobile device management
or MDM. And in most organizations, there
are a set of standards associated with
these mobile devices. So there might be
a certain requirement for passwords,
lock screens, what's allowed or not
allowed on that device, and many other
options. All of these policies can be
added to a single profile, and that
profile can be associated with all of
the devices on your network. This might
include configuration options, so all of
the different settings that you need to
be able to access your corporate email
may be part of this profile. And
security options for lock screens and
data encryption could also be enabled or
disabled in any of these security
profiles. And security options for
encrypting all of your data, locking the
screen, and the type of passcode you
might be able to use might also be added
to one of these profiles. You would
normally build one of these profiles,
add it to your mobile device manager,
and then have the mobile device manager
push those out to all of your devices.
Let's start with a process of creating
one of these configuration profiles. You
can use Microsoft Intoune or Apple
Configurator to provide a nice frontend
where you can easily see your options
and enable or disable different
features. For example, you might want to
add to your profile information about
Exchange Active Sync. So, you can add
the Active Sync account name, the Active
Sync host name, whether you'd like to
use SSL, and any other important
configuration parameters. Security
features are also in here, so you can
find information about VPN,
certificates, and other security
features that you might want to enable
or disable. Most of these configuration
programs will create a single profile
represented in XML. This is a standard
format and can be read by many different
applications. That profile can then be
added to a mobile device manager like
the one we see here. This MDM screen is
drilled down into my iPhone and I can
enable or disable any of the features on
that phone all from this single
management console. For example, if I
click on the security option, I can
define information about passcodes. I
can define whether I would like to
require a complex passcode or even
require alpha numeric as part of the
passcode. I can define minimum password
lengths, whether I would like this to
have a password age and how long that
would be and other important security
parameters. Once I built this profile, I
can save this and now use it across
multiple devices on my network.
Just as we have updates for our desktops
and laptop computers, we also need to
make sure that we provide updates for
our mobile devices. Most mobile devices
have the update process built into the
operating system itself. These updates
might provide device patches, especially
security updates, and these might come
on a regular basis. There might also be
operating system updates that fix
problems with existing operating system
features or add new features to the
device. You might also be running many
different applications on these mobile
devices and each of these apps also has
to be updated. Most of these updates
occur in the background or at night when
you're asleep. This way we're able to
deploy those updates seamlessly and keep
the system up and running with the
latest software.
And just as we have anti virus and
anti-malware software for our desktop
operating systems, we also have options
for our mobile devices. This might be
different depending on the operating
system you're using. With Apple iOS, the
entire environment is completely closed.
The only way to install software onto
that device is from the Apple App Store.
If malware wants to find its way onto
your iPhone, it needs to take advantage
of a vulnerability that has not already
been patched. The Android operating
system is a bit more open. There's no
centralized store that everyone must go
through. Instead, you can install
software from any website. This provides
a much easier way for malware and other
malicious software to find its way onto
your Android device. Fortunately,
there's anti virus software available
for both iOS and Android. So, you can
download this software from known anti
virus providers to help keep your mobile
devices safer. These mobile devices can
also support content filtering. So, if
you would like to prevent someone from
visiting certain websites or from
running certain applications, you can
enable this capability on all of your
mobile devices.
One of the things you've undoubtedly
used with your mobile device is a way to
view where that device may be located.
There is a locator application built
into most mobile devices, and it
integrates with GPS and other mobile
networks to pinpoint exactly where your
device might be. This usually shows a
map where it provides an icon of exactly
where your device may be located. And if
that device is moving, you will see it
move in real time on this map. Although
you may not have direct control of this
mobile device, you might still be able
to play a sound or put a notification on
the screen for someone to read. And if
you feel that this device is lost and
you're not going to be able to recover
it, you can choose to mark this device
as lost and erase all of your personal
data on that mobile phone.
Traditional backup methods don't work
very well for a mobile device. These
devices are in a different place all the
time. They might not be in the same
place every day, and it's difficult to
find a time to plug it in to be able to
back up all of the data. Fortunately,
most of these devices integrate with a
cloud-based backup service, which works
perfectly for the mobility associated
with these mobile phones and tablets.
This is something that is constantly
backing up these devices so you always
know that you're going to have the most
recent information always stored in the
cloud. This is also using our wireless
networks and our cellular networks to
provide this backup. So we don't have to
plug in a cable or wait for a backup to
occur just to have a backup of all of
our data. And the process for
restoration is just as easy. We simply
log into our cloud account. It begins
downloading everything to our new
device, and we now have restored from a
completely cloud-based backup system.
Most of our mobile phones and tablets
don't include a separate firewall app.
That's because most of the activity on
these devices is going outbound, and
there's very few cases where you're
using that device as an inbound server.
But if you did want to download a
separate firewall app, there are many
options available on Android. Not quite
as many available on iOS, but even those
applications seem to be rarely used. In
most enterprise environments, the
security for that device is defined on
the mobile device manager. And that
manager can determine whether someone is
able to connect to a website, download
information, or install certain
applications on their mobile device.
For that reason, most organizations will
have a clearly defined set of policies
and procedures for how these devices are
to be used. This starts with how the
device is acquired to begin with. Many
organizations will manage both
company-owned devices and userowned
devices from a single mobile device
manager. And if it is a userowned
device, you might see this referred to
as a BYOD, where it's a bring your own
device. We've already seen how the MDM
can be the central point for all
management for all of these mobile
devices. And if you are defining
policies and procedures, you can
integrate those policies into the MDM
and push those out to all of the devices
on your network. So you may be in a
highly secure environment and one of
your company policies may be that no
photography is allowed inside of the
building. You can create a profile in
your mobile device manager that matches
that policy or procedure within your
company and push out that policy to all
of your mobile devices. That way, anyone
entering the building will automatically
find that their camera is no longer
working. And as we've already seen, we
can even include security features. So,
if you want to force a particular type
of passcode or enable full disk
encryption on a device, you can set all
of those policies within your mobile
device manager.